Wir sind in der Ukraine. Auf dem
Flughafen der Hauptstadt Kiew.
Der Luzerner Alexander Hug
fliegt heute zum letzten Mal
in den Osten des Landes.
Dort wird nach wie vor gekämpft,
fast jede Woche sterben Menschen.
Noch eine Frage:
Wie ist das Gefühl
vor der letzten Reise?
So wie vor jeder.
Es gibt noch viel zu klären
vor der letzten Reise.
Keine speziellen Emotionen?
Noch nicht.
Ich habe jetzt keine Zeit dafür.
Vielleicht auf dem Rückweg.
Grosse Emotionen
sind nicht seine Aufgabe.
Er muss so neutral wie möglich sein.
Alexander Hug ist stellvertretender
Chef-Beobachter der OSZE
im Ukrainekrieg.
Seine Arbeit hätte mithelfen sollen,
Frieden in dieses Land zu bringen.
Nach viereinhalb Jahren
geht sein Einsatz zu Ende.
Zurück bleibt der Krieg.
Was für ein Mensch muss man sein,
um im Kreuzfeuer
eines bewaffneten Konfliktes
scheinbar emotionslos zu arbeiten.
Davon handelt dieser Film.
Rund 700 internationale Beobachter
arbeiten in Hugs Mission.
Mit einer Gruppe
fährt er zur sog. Kontaktlinie.
Im äussersten Osten der Ukraine
befindet sich diese Kontaktlinie,
die eigentlich eine Frontlinie ist -
rund 500 km lang.
Hier kämpfen ukrainische Regierungs-
truppen gegen lokale Separatisten,
die allerdings von Russland
entscheidend unterstützt
und wohl auch befehligt werden.
Der Kreml bestreitet das.
Russland
will offensichtlich verhindern,
dass die prowestliche Regierung
in Kiew
die Ukraine in die EU
und in die NATO führt.
Panzerwagen
der ukrainischen Regierungstruppen.
Wir sind ganz nahe der Front und
fahren ins lang umkämpfte Dorf Pesky.
Zur Ruhe gekommen
ist das Dorf seit Jahren nicht.
Um noch Einwohner zu finden,
muss man lange suchen.
* Ein Hund bellt. *
Du hast aber kalte Hände.
Es ist schon in Ordnung.
Er hat eine gute Jacke.
It will be all fine.
Die alte Frau scheint Alexander Hug
schon zu kennen.
Sie beklagt sich über die Kämpfe.
Eine Zeit lang
flogen hier ständig Granaten.
Ich habe ums Haus herum
schon 38 Einschläge gezählt.
Der Hof und alles ist kaputt.
Nur mein Sohn und ich
sind noch hier.
Ich bin 80 und er 54.
Darum, Alexanderchen,
pass du besser auf dich selber auf
und auf deine Kinder und deine Frau!
Ich werde Sie niemals vergessen.
Ich werde dich
auch nie vergessen, mein Sohn.
Haben Sie diese Frau
schon früher getroffen?
Jedes Mal, wenn wir hier in dieses
Dorf kommen, treffen wir diese Frau.
Heute ist es das letzte Mal,
dass wir sie sehen.
Es leben noch acht andere Menschen
im grösseren Raum von Pesky.
Aber wird hier noch geschossen?
Ja, v.a. in der Nacht,
aber man sieht auch,
dass fast alle Häuser
durch das Militär besetzt sind.
D.h., es gibt wohl auch Stellungen
hier in der Nähe.
Und das bringt auch immer
die Zivilbevölkerung,
die hier noch lebt, in Gefahr.
Das Leben der Menschen
hier erträglicher zu machen,
dafür setzt sich Hug
seit viereinhalb Jahren ein.
Ein intensiver Job für den Juristen
und ehemaligen Offizier
der Schweizer Armee.
Meist müssen 5 Std. Schlaf reichen.
Dabei war seine Einsatzzeit
ursprünglich
nur für sechs Monate geplant.
Wenn Sie das am Anfang gewusst
hätten, hätten Sie Ja gesagt?
Das kann ich im Nachhinein
nicht sagen.
Man hat das zu keinem Zeitpunkt
am Anfang gedacht,
dass das zu einem vollen Konflikt
führen würde,
der so lange dauern wird.
Und dass zum Zeitpunkt
des heutigen Tages
noch keine wirkliche Lösung
in Sicht sein würde.
Wie alt waren Ihre Kinder damals?
Meine Jüngste war fünf Monate,
als das Ganze angefangen hat,
d.h., sie ist inzwischen
fünf Jahre alt.
Sie läuft und redet,
was noch nicht der Fall war,
als ich damals von daheim
nach Kiew abgereist bin.
Aber sie kennt den Papa?
Sie kennt den Papa
und wartet auf den Papa.
Mind. eine Woche pro Monat
war Alexander Hug
in den letzten Jahren
im Konfliktgebiet.
Sich selber ein Bild machen,
um danach starke Argumente zu haben
für die schwierigen Verhandlungen
mit den militärischen
und politischen Verantwortlichen.
Als Korrespondent
war ich selber oft in dieser Region
und habe dabei
Alexander Hug mehrmals getroffen.
Erstmals im Juli 2014,
hier vor den Trümmern
der Boeing Malaysia Airlines MH17.
Abgeschossen
über dem ostukrainischen Himmel.
Fast 300 unschuldige Männer,
Frauen und Kinder starben.
Die Bilder mit Hug bei der
Absturzstelle gingen um die Welt.
Damals konnte er zeigen, welches
die Stärke seiner Mission ist.
Er und seine Beobachter
sind bestens vernetzt mit den
verschiedenen Kriegsparteien.
Die Kühlwagen mit den Leichen
waren damals
auf dem Territorium der Separatisten
und mussten über die Frontlinie
auf die Seite der Regierungstruppen
transportiert werden.
Hug vermittelte.
Können Sie mir Ihr Wort geben,
dass dieser Zug heute hier wegfährt?
Wir müssen die Leichenwagen
jetzt endlich wegbringen.
Schon damals
gab es viele Indizien dafür,
was wir aufgrund
der Untersuchungsberichte
mit grosser Wahrscheinlichkeit
wissen.
Es war eine Rakete
der russischen Armee,
die das Flugzeug abgeschossen hatte.
Auf Spekulationen
liess sich Hug aber nie ein.
Die OSZE-Spezialmission ist nicht
dazu da, die Untersuchung zu führen
oder die Leichen zu bergen.
Wir sind hier, um zu berichten,
was die Mission vor Ort sieht,
und die Berichte
werden an 57 Staaten weitergereicht.
Seit jenen Tagen
ist der heute 46-jährige Hug
d a s  Gesicht der Mission.
Er nimmt regelmässig an Patrouillen
teil, will ein Vorbild sein.
Oftmals wurde es gefährlich.
Mehrmals gerieten Hug und
andere Beobachter unter Beschuss.
Ein Mitarbeiter
starb nach einer Minenexplosion.
Dass Hug die Hotspots
trotzdem regelmässig besuchte,
rechnen ihm hier auch
die Kämpfer und Militärs hoch an.
Wir fahren zu einer
ukrainischen Polizei-Akademie.
Hier will Hug einmal mehr
die Arbeit der OSZE,
der Organisation für Sicherheit und
Zusammenarbeit in Europa erklären.
Die OSZE ist die grösste, regionale
Sicherheitsorganisation der Welt.
Sie besteht aus 57 Mitgliedsstaaten,
darunter auch Russland
und die Ukraine.
In Minsk wurde im Februar 2015
eigentlich
ein Waffenstillstand ausgehandelt.
Aber an den hält sich
keine der beiden Seiten.
Die OSZE-Mission in der Ukraine
hat die Aufgabe,
Fakten darüber zu sammeln,
wann und wo das Waffenstillstands-
abkommen verletzt wird.
So filmten Drohnen,
wie russische Konvois,
wahrscheinlich militärische, nachts
heimlich in die Ukraine fuhren.
Oder wie
getarnte ukrainische Haubitzen
nahe der Kontaktlinie stehen,
wo sie nicht sein dürften.
Über 10'000 Menschen kamen bis heute
bei diesem Krieg ums Leben.
Hunderttausende
mussten ihr Heim verlassen.
Der Westen sieht Russland
als treibende Kriegspartei
und hält darum seit Jahren die
Sanktionen gegen Russland aufrecht.
In Moskau
sieht man es gerade umgekehrt.
Alexander Hug weiss genau:
Es geht hier im ukrainischen Donbass
um Geopolitik.
Das zeigt sich auch
bei seinem nächsten Treffen.
Hug empfängt eine Delegation
von US-amerikanischen Diplomaten.
Alexander Hug. Nice to meet you.
Ihre Arbeit
ist ja inzwischen legendär.
Wir würden gerne mehr wissen,
was funktioniert und was nicht.
Wohin die Mission geht
und wie wir behilflich sein könnten.
Thank you.
I think now w'ell continue ...
Ich selber muss draussen bleiben.
Ich frage mich,
ob Hug auch hinter verschlossenen
Türen radikal neutral ist.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Die Amerikaner sind ja ziemlich klar,
wenn es um die Rolle Russlands
in diesem Konflikt geht.
Die OSZE ist da vorsichtiger.
Schauen Sie, für uns ist es
ganz klar der Fehler der Russen.
Sie haben zuerst
die Krim annektiert.
Und sie beliefern
die ostukrainischen Separatisten
mit Waffen
und anderer Unterstützung.
Dafür machen wir sie verantwortlich.
Kann ich eine Frage stellen?
Sie sind ja gegenüber Journalisten
sehr neutral und vorsichtig.
Sind Sie hinter verschlossenen Türen
klarer im Urteil?
Man muss auch hinter verschlossenen
Türen diplomatisch bleiben.
Schlussendlich
vertreten wir nicht nur
einen Teilnehmerstaat
sondern 57 Teilnehmerstaaten.
Er sagt z.B. jetzt, Russland sei klar
ein Teil des Konflikts.
Das ist die Meinung
von eines Teilnehmerstaates.
Wie gesagt,
ich vertrete 57 Teilnehmerstaaten.
Ich habe eine persönliche Meinung,
die hat aber hier nichts zu suchen.
Hug und seine Beobachter
notieren also Tausende
von Waffenstillstandsverletzungen.
Sie sagen auch wo und wann.
Aber wer schiesst?
Diese Frage lassen sie offen.
Wir fahren noch einmal
zur Kontaktlinie.
Wir wollen vom Gebiet,
das von den ukrainischen
Regierungstruppen kontrolliert wird,
auf die andere Seite zu den von
Russland unterstützten Separatisten.
Eine Grenze innerhalb eines Landes,
die es eigentlich
gar nicht geben dürfe.
Denn die Menschen hier
gehören zusammen.
Oft sind Freunde oder Familien-
mitglieder voneinander getrennt.
Der Übergang ist eine Brücke,
die nur mehr zu Fuss passierbar ist.
Hug muss sich hier von seinen Fahrern
verabschieden - für immer.
Archivbilder der Separatisten zeigen,
wie 2014 um diese Brücke
hart gekämpft wurde.
* Knall *
* Gewehrsalven *
2015 wurde sie gesprengt.
Seither können
keine Fahrzeuge mehr passieren.
Tausende von Menschen müssen täglich
eine lange Strecke zu Fuss gehen,
um ihre Rentengelder zu beziehen,
für Spitalbesuche
oder um Angehörige zu sehen.
Links und rechts sind Minenfelder.
* Knall *
Explosionen oder Schüsse in der Nähe
scheinen hier niemanden mehr
sonderlich zu beeindrucken.
Um über die Brücke zu kommen,
muss man mehrere Checkpoints
passieren. Das kann Stunden dauern.
Überall, wo Hug auftritt, wird er
mit derselben Frage konfrontiert:
Wann ist das alles endlich vorbei?
Ich hoffe bald.
Ich begleite Alexander Hug
von der OSZE.
Er macht doch nichts, euer Hug.
Er hilft nicht.
Es geht uns hier
genauso schlecht wie früher.
Das ist doch kein Zustand hier.
Ständig muss man zu Fuss
über diese Grenze. Eine Zumutung.
Viele Menschen hier verstehen
die Aufgabe der Beobachter nicht.
Fast schon gebetsmühlenartig
muss sich Hug erklären.
Noch einmal.
Die Mission hat in Tausenden von
täglichen Berichten dokumentiert,
wie die Menschen hier leiden
und mit welchen Schwierigkeiten
sie leben müssen.
Diese Informationen
sind für alle zugänglich,
auch für diejenigen,
die hier die Entscheidungen treffen.
Genau diese Entscheidungsträger
müssten aber die Berichte lesen
und dann Schritte einleiten,
um die Situation zu verbessern.
Die Frustration der Menschen -
Hug bekommt sie oft zu spüren.
Ich frage mich, wo er bis zum letzten
Tag seine Motivation hernimmt.
Ich weiss, dass es möglich ist,
den Konflikt
in die richtige Richtung zu rücken.
Und ich weiss, dass aufgeben
oder den Konflikt so zu akzeptieren,
wie er jetzt ist,
nichts zur Lösungsfindung beiträgt.
Dann müssen wir noch
über eine provisorische Holzbrücke
auf die andere Seite.
Dort warten Vertreter der prorus-
sischen Separatisten bereits auf Hug.
Guten Tag. Wir haben Sie
vor einer Stunde erwartet.
Tut mir leid, aber ich wollte hier
noch mit den Menschen reden.
Then we don't say goodbye now.
See you.
Die von Russland
unterstützten Separatisten
haben hier in der Region
von Lugansk und Donezk
zwei selbstständige Republiken
ausgerufen.
Man fühlt sich fast wieder
wie in der Sowjetunion.
Autoritäre Militärregime,
die die Freiheitsrechte der Menschen
stark einschränken.
Das gilt auch für die Medien.
Alexander Hug
hält eine Pressekonferenz.
Die anwesenden Journalisten
stellen v.a. Fragen
im Sinne der lokalen Machthaber.
Die Menschen hier
beschuldigen die OSZE oft,
dass diese mit der ukrainischen
Armee und den Geheimdiensten
gemeinsame Sache mache.
Können Sie
diese Zusammenarbeit kommentieren?
Wir haben ein Mandat,
um mit allen Stellen in der Ukraine
Kontakte zu haben.
Nach viereinhalb Jahren
sollte man endlich aufhören,
gegenseitig mit dem Finger
aufeinander zu zeigen.
Das hat bis heute nichts gebracht.
Das gilt auch für euch Journalisten.
Wir alle sollten versuchen,
die Entscheidungsträger
dahingehend zu beeinflussen,
dass diese Lösungen finden
und nicht
noch mehr Probleme schaffen.
Hugs letzte Pressekonferenz
endet aber keineswegs im Streit.
Die Medienvertreter
möchten noch ein Selfie mit ihm.
Hug habe seine Arbeit gut gemacht,
erzählt mir eine Journalistin.
Thank you very much.
Ganz anders tönt es dann am Abend,
als ich im Hotel die lokalen
Fernsehnachrichten schaue.
Hug hat oftmals völlig grundlos die
Behörden von Lugansk beschuldigt,
sie würden die Arbeit der Beobachter
behindern.
Immer wieder erfindet er Vorwürfe
gegenüber Lugansk und Donezk.
Gleichzeitig
hat er stets daran gearbeitet,
die Verbrechen der ukrainischen
Terroristen zu vertuschen.
Kaum zu glauben,
wie Hugs Worte verdreht werden.
Am nächsten Tag
hagelt es nochmals Kritik,
diesmal von ukrainischer Seite.
Geplant war eigentlich, Zivilisten
an der Frontlinie zu besuchen.
Doch das fällt aus.
Alle scheinen angespannt.
In der Nacht wurde Hug
in einer bekannten amerikanischen
Zeitung falsch zitiert.
Er habe gesagt, es gebe keine Beweise
für eine russische Militärpräsenz
in der Ostukraine.
Die ukrainischen Medien laufen Sturm.
Hohe Regierungsvertreter
schiessen gegen Hug.
Einen ganzen Tag lang kommunizieren
er und sein ganzes Team
mit ukrainischen Journalisten
und Politikern.
Inwieweit
haben Sie darunter gelitten,
dass Sie keine private Meinung
äussern dürfen?
Dass Sie immer kühl, sachlich
und neutral bleiben mussten
und nie auf den Tisch
klopfen und sagen konnten:
"Diese oder diese Partei ist schuld"!
Ich habe früh gelernt,
dass es in dem Umfeld des Konfliktes
gar nichts bringt,
wenn man emotional reagiert
oder sogar eine Seite bezieht.
Über kurz oder lang wird man
ein Bestandteil des Problems
und wird dann unbrauchbar
als Lösungsfinder.
Man kann dann vielleicht
eine Seite mehr unterstützen.
Aber auf eine lange Sicht,
und auf eine nachhaltige
Lösungsfindung ausgerichtet,
würde ein emotionales Handeln
nichts bringen.
Eine rationale Antwort.
Trotzdem spüre ich,
dass Hug die Unterstellungen
und Anfeindungen nahegehen.
Dazu äussern will er sich aber nicht,
um nicht
noch mehr Öl ins Feuer zu giessen.
Wir fahren ein letztes Mal
an den Stadtrand von Donezk,
in einen umkämpften Aussenbezirk.
Dort passieren wir den letzten
Checkpoint der Separatisten.
Danach sind wir
in der sog. grauen Zone.
Hier sind die Menschen
sich selbst überlassen.
Wir hören,
dass in der Ferne geschossen wird.
Das Gespräch mit der Bevölkerung
wird von uniformierten Separatisten
überwacht.
Für uns wäre das Wichtigste,
dass der Beschuss aufhört.
Wir träumen einfach
von einem normalen Leben.
Aber Sie waren doch schon hier
bei uns, vor zwei Jahren.
Erinnern Sie sich,
als die alte Frau so geweint hatte.
So endet auch der letzte der vielen
Frontbesuche mit der Frage,
auf die Alexander Hug
keine Antwort geben kann:
Wann das alles aufhört.
Hug weiss genau, dass dieser Konflikt
erst gelöst werden kann,
wenn sich der Westen und Russland
wieder näherkommen.
Zum Abschied kann er den Mitarbeitern
nur Durchhalteparolen
mit auf den Weg geben.
Ich bitte euch,
macht weiter mit eurer Arbeit!
Gebt nicht auf. Auch wenn sie euch
sehr frustrierend erscheint.
Eine endgültige Lösung
für die Beendigung des Konfliktes
ist nicht in Sicht.
Aber wir wissen alle:
Konflikte enden früher oder später.
Und so auch dieser. Und ihr habt
dabei eine Rolle zu spielen.
Eine Panzersperre!
Das ist passend für diese Region.
Ich will Ihnen Danke sagen
im Namen von uns allen.
Sie waren immer ein Vorbild
für uns - aus zwei Gründen:
Wegen Ihrer Integrität
und wegen Ihres mutigen Einsatzes.
Das ist das,
was Ihnen jeder von uns,
das ganze Team, mitgeben möchte.
Thank you very much.
And take care of our people here!
- Of course.
We'll meet soon again,
somewhere elso.  Of course.
Wie seine Zukunft aussehe,
wisse er noch nicht.
Zuerst will er Zeit mit der Familie
und seinen Eltern verbringen.
Aber es gebe interessante Optionen,
z.B. eine Mission in Syrien.